E
UNITED STATES AND ALL AROUND THE
INEW DAHIS MOG,ULD L
TO BLE GE ON THEID B
BE HASING TO THE AMERICAN PE
ET C'T SURE ABOUT
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS ATNT THE
AN5 DEATHS ALL OF A DDEN,E'BOTHT
PRTE G IA HEOR PHOTO OP O
WALTER RONE VETERAN SECRET SERG.
>>AST TEN PEOE
CIRCLE A N F, T SENATORS,
GOVERNSTIE.
HE IS IN THITAL THIS MORNING, I
22 STATES REPORT RISINENUMBERS.
CASESROPPINGNL  THIS IN US NOW
HE C
ANNEOU
HE IS ONEHITE HOUSENALISTS WHOI
PRESIDENT IS DOOU DOINGHIS
OKAY.ITELY A
UNCOORWO
FOLKS.
IKE YOU HAV
YOU KNOW, THE PAINS
AND CHISTILL HAVE AFEVER THATE
FOR SEVERAL DA
IT'S DEFINITELY NOT COMFORTABL
IT'SOU SORH T IN THEHOSPITAL.
AND I CERTAINLY LUCKY WHENAR TH
HAVE HAD TSE THAVE.
>> AND YOU ARE DOING YPORTING,
TORY AND TO  H IS
GREAT. T
YOU HAVELTIVE DETAIL I WANT YOU
AG WALR RER
NOW, I KNEW THEY'LL DOHEWARD, PT
THE ST
WHAT THEY'RE FOCUSED BUT
HAVE TO BELIEVE THERE AROT
FEELINGS GOING I WAS SHOCKHEN
IMAGES PRESIDENT IN THE
US THE
BLOCK, ESSENTIAL F C.
AT STO, I ROVERBIAL
EXAT
COMPLETE DISREGARD
HEY ME.
AN KNOW,CKAGO,HESE W
O OUR
HEAL PROTOCOLS
TE WHITE HOUSE
, SPECIFICALLY
THE MEDICAL UNIT,ND
SERVICE NEEDED TO BELEMENTEDO WO
TH SHODITAL.
WE SHOULITICAL
ADHO ARE --OW CONTRACT HAVE EN
D OAE GET THE ORFROM THE DISEAS.
HAVE  THEALTH SIT
THE VERY BEGI
>> THEUPPOSED QUAN WE HA B
HE NINEHS,
YSYMPTOMS,
BY  YVOIDVE'T GO OUT INPUBLIC,
PEOPLE.MEAN, TTHE TOLD US, FOR
THESE NINEHS.
AND THAT THE ISE,
MICHF WHAHENEINSIDE, A TWA TSUPD
BUT TH,SIDENT KEPTG AOR E
FR WIDEN LL OFFUND-RAISERS.
AND WHY ITE E  LAST G
NEGATIVE?AT?'T THE AMERICADESEW
SOY OTHEREOOT
>> RIGHT, LOOK T
.
ONE THERE
YOU KNOW,FFERENT SET OF RULESN E
NG OUR  HAVINHESE TERRIBLE MOB
CHILDREN'S  WHICH I
AND PRESIDENT SORT
OF EVADE THE KIND OF RULES THAIN
ON SAID TO US THE THING THAT'T.
ISUT EVERYINUTETAIL ABOUT W WHE
AND I W S NOW, YYS, DAYS OR
THINK I WAS
PROBABLY INFECTED ON TTTURDAY B.
NOTE HOUSE HAS  ANYTHING
T WHERWA I
TALKED TO OR WHO ELSE I MIGHT
HAVE INFE. THINKT JUST STHAT THI
AT LEAST AS ITTA
BIG DEAL, MICHAEL.HA ALL, Y T R
NIGHT, BY ,IR FORCE IDENT OFF T
SO IF HE IOUS, IT'S
NOT IMPOSSIBLE.
WAS HE WEARING WHEN HE
SPOKE TO YOU?S NOHE WAS NOT WEA
TEOF
IT'S HARD TO KNOW,RIGHT, IFD JU
THAT DAY, THE M
THK  GUYS
PLAGUE WOULD WS
AT THAT POINT.
I ERE ROSEARE EVENT, BUT WHEN Y
COVID TEST EARLIER IN THE Y, I
US.
IT'S POSSIBL RAN INTOME ED.
BUT IT'S - BUT TT HE IME
HOUSE AND LAST TIME,
WAS OUT R,MEWHERE ALO O IS WHERT
>> AND JUST O
TRACING.
YOU HAVEN'T BEEN HAT PEERT EVEN.
THAT'SUNDING THAT TELLBOTH
RI ANDCEDWMEAN, IT'S A MICROCOS
A LARGERHERE.
IF THEY' CONCERNED ABOUTATWHATYE
IT AIG ISSUE?>>,
RESULT O POLITICS THATAVHE
VIRUS FROM THE VERY BEGINNING,
RIGHETR
FIASCOS EARLY AND NOTAV TESTINGT
TRUMP DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE MORE
CASE WHETHER IT EVELOPMENT A
PRESSURE ANDCD
ITN
PO I THI THAT EVEN GETS DOWNTO W
PEOPLE IN THE BUILDINGIDWANTDNT,
MONTHS ATOR
WE NEVER TAKE T OFF, UNLESS
YOU'REING A S DRINK ORSOMETHING
WOULD ALWAYSOMNONE OFM  LAST CDT
THOSET
SERVICE AGENTS, WE THINN THKNOWT
NEGATI TWA KNOW IF
HE'S STILL TESTISITIVE IF HE HA.
DON'NOHAT'SHAPPENING.ICE
AGENTS ARE PROFESSIONALS, BUTOW
THERMORNING AND RWARD?
LL, I TORTANT AND I'VE SAIDND VE
CONS TO
WHENSRUS, KNOW, OVIRONMTHOPYE T.
THERRD ORDOF CONSEQE.
THERE'S RPLEFFEOU
B W B
EX SECRET  FAMILIES AND PEOPLE
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THATHEY
ATE
SO, LDT IMPACT TO THE SECRET SE
I LL AGENTS, ARVISORS SPEAKST
AND A LOT OF I TO DO WITH
THE RANO ONENOWS WHO'SF  POLICI
AROUND WHITEUSE.
IST THE WHITE HOUSE MEDICAL
UNIT?US OPERATIONS?
Y  SEEMS L THERE'S
SOMEBODY ELSE CHHO WE HAVE HAD B
WET  AG